very good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
look it's going on its own that's that's
that's the way things work in India and
everything takes a life of its own
it all goes well for the future all
right so I'm going to give you a brief
idea about the status of art
conservation in India so this was a
conference we had last year it was
attended by about 300 people from around
the country we call it steady steps
ahead a lot of connotations to the way
you think of the word steady steps ahead
and it brought to the fore the fact that
there is an alive Khan's art
conservation community in the country in
terms of the distribution if I look at a
strategy if you look at the distribution
of custodians in the country you have
the government sections and you have the
private owners that trust the private
universities a very huge amount of
India's cultural heritage is with the
monasteries and religious art has always
been in either the temporal domain or
the with the spectrum you know so
monasteries and religious institutions
hold a huge amount of cultural heritage
in the country and then the general
population in terms of the way the
custodians are distributed we have the
distribution of the practitioners so
while in terms of nomenclature differs
in the government they call them
chemists or things because of the way
when the Archaeological Survey was
established that was the nomenclature
and but in the other in the other
sectors where they have picked on the
terminology which is internationally
accepted as conservator restorers a very
big amount and an important a very big
practitioner base is the custodian
because of the lack of the conservation
professionals the custodians play a very
important role in the conservation of
cultural heritage so they are there you
have a lot of certificate holders who do
a lot of short-term workshops and things
and they come across into the field as
people who can practice so it's an
interesting situation in India where
ironically there are a lot of resources
suddenly
made available but the training has been
half-baked so it's ten years back there
were not enough people right and the
people who were willing to work did not
have the resources today the resources
are there with the people are not there
you have the also the a lot of people
who deal with the ethnographic objects
in India and these are the people who
also who delve into the conservation
practice into conservation practice then
you have a number of local resource
persons who are then sourced by the
custodians to do some work and
conservation and then you have a lot of
not a lot of a few people who are coming
from around the world now and doing work
in different parts of country through
NGOs and other things so this makes the
conservation community in India so other
than the people to be trained for formal
art conservation I think we have to
address also that larger thing to
address this huge country of ours we
have to address a conservation training
also on these on this front also the
trick is to take it forward and once
backwards and you get to it the training
delivery platform we have degrees and
diplomas right we have certificate
courses we have informal training we
have workshops and we have people
working in studios so this is the way
training is imparted at the moment in
India there is I think a strategy
opportunity also of involving what the
Government of India has it's called the
Department of Personnel training do PT
and the polytechnics in India and I
think once we go through this it reaches
the entire country in a big way so this
is not just for art objects but it also
could be also be linked to heritage
conservation in terms of structures and
buildings and built heritage the
opportunities post-training
in terms of these delivery platforms are
the state institutions in India have a
lot of positions many of them are filled
by the blue dots show you that these are
filled by people who did not have formal
training earlier and they man the posts
at the moment right at the same time we
have the red ones where they have
finally accepted the now
terminology of the trained conservator
restorers so you must remember that
policy plays a big role in this and we
have to also address that in the private
sector the people who are coming into
the profession are people who are
trained in the formal manner through
established programs in terms of if I
say five requirements in India at the
moment one is how to approach the
conservation issue is a thing that needs
to be imparted to the people who are to
be when the curriculums are to be
created the creation of work spaces is
very important people can do the work
but if you ask them to create your work
space I think that becomes an issue
sometimes with the institutions with the
practitioners so the third is what to do
with your available resources there is a
blind sort of leaning towards materials
which are not readily available in your
local environment but the fact is that
all these things are readily available
with markets opening up now for the
holes the world's one playing field so
all these resources are available it's
the trouble with things in India perhaps
in other developing countries is not the
availability of resources it is the
optimum utilization of the resources
conservation decisions and then
recording and reporting these are five
sectors which I think are very very
crucial to conservation training in
India other than the formal training of
a conservator as Deborah articulated an
exposure in apprenticeships play a great
role in this the to paddle gaps in India
in terms of training one is the line the
most important thing is language if you
see the number of people in India if
you're looking at a billion people how
many of them know English and out of
those people who know English how many
of them are actually interested in art
and culture and how many of them are
then the conservators so if all the
training is only in English we are just
skimming the surface of the country and
if we want our conservation training to
go further little bit into the soil of
the nation we have to have our the Lok
not the local languages but at least one
official there 22 official language
so at least in those regions that
language and English simultaneously and
that will be a strategy that we are
working on for the next five years to
address in India this is an opportune
time I just give you a few slides before
I close of the we established this five
years back the CSM vs art Conservation
Center we have been working on a huge
number of projects we have a team of 35
people at the moment we work on a range
of variety of materials and technologies
from contemporary art to ancient art
archaeological objects and their areas
that we are further developing workshops
and training courses are an important
part of a curriculum we have lots of
interns coming from different
departments in various universities as
well as people who are training actually
for conservation the trainings are held
not only in our Center but also we do
external trainings in other parts of the
country we provide exhibition supports
and a lot of institutions are coming to
India with exhibitions and we take care
of entire collection care
responsibilities in collaboration with
them our research and all is based on
our day to day work things where we can
provide solutions high end research is
something that one can do with other
institutions who have the facilities
textile conservation is an area that
we're going to concentrate on we are
bringing in new technologies into the
country because that was my alarm I
thought I thought this was a dream and I
just woke up this is this is the way
we've been working on things here one of
the issues was there was not enough
sharing of the materials and the
database and the experience the
conservation experience in India for
which we created this art conservation
resurgence project over three years
we've been documenting materials
technologies and and now we're going to
publish a series of these reference
documents for public access including
many of you in fact the sites are alive
and you could go to these sites in due
course and this has informed custodians
across the country this is that huge
when you go to India next you see the
intern
they put in Bombay 7000 ethnographic
objects from around the country have
been put together on a 2.5 kilometer
long exhibition within the museum's all
these objects came from around the
country then you have the preventive
conservation in the various monastic
institutions that we've been working on
we've been working with craftspeople
and we've been working with architects
and stonemasons with traditional systems
and knowledge and we have a good Network
across the country so it's time to take
it forward thank you very much ladies
and gentlemen